Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
full Star Wars and or episode 5 video there were
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them careful
for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll just start at the beginning and work
our way through shop by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments starting with the title the
episode was titled the axe forgets a reference to
Arvel saying the ax forgets but the tree remembers
it was his metaphor for the Empire forgetting
about them when they were growing up and many
others that they grind down in their prisons the
work camps facilities for processing children and
they are the trees that grow up as children in
that system and then remember what the empire
did to them coming back for revenge later and it's
meant to be a big part of why they're doing this
creating the rebellion and I believe they also
reference the Rebellion by name in the episode
for the first time I don't think we've actually
heard them refer to it as the Rebellion at least
in an episode yet this episode was mostly about
them beginning The Heist and kind of showing you
the Imperial base for the first time in also
showing you a little bit more around Coruscant
and some of the other planets now I'm assuming
the entire Heist just takes place in next week's
episode unless it winds up being like a really
long Heist or really short episode and there's
a cliffhanger the actual opening scene starts
with Karn having gone back to his mother's with
his tail between his legs trying to find a new job
basically that's a whole conversation he has with
his mother about finding new prospects she seems
very ambitious for her son it also kind of looks
like he's eating a version of space Cocoa Puffs
here that a little bit green and they have some
blue milk which obviously Big Star Wars thing
blue milk when she references the conversation
with the uncle about this job that he might
wind up getting I think the idea is that it's
going to push him in the direction of the Empire
or something that will throw him back into the
story because he looks at the picture of Andor
that he has on file and in the first couple of
episodes I thought of him as being kind of like
an Inspector Javert Les Mis type of character
like the person who won't let it go who will just
pursue him to the end of their days because that's
basically what Dedra is doing on the Empire side
of things we might see Karn also join the empire
that might be the job that they think that he
should get oh you should Advance your prospects
join the Empire he already has the vibe of an
imperial character to begin with then we see
Andor wake up his Rebellion study manual all this
stuff is gone they're investigating because the
whole idea is that none of them really trust
each other that much and he's like brand new
to the group it's a big thing in the episode of
them not totally trusting him the corporate issue
Blaster that he references is the one he stole off
the men that he killed in episode one like where
did you get this I didn't really get their names
the way arvel talks about his tattoos they seem
like they're from various Imperial institutions
that he grew up in as a child until he eventually
decided to join the Rebellion the one for the
crate head is a reference to the crate dragon
from Tatooine obviously which we saw during the
events of the Mandalorian like we actually saw a
real crate Dragon the phrase by the hand I think
is a reference to the emperor's hand which were
like the super Commandos that they featured during
Rebels so it sounds like arvel actually used to be
an imperial super Commando before he chose to
join the Rebellion when Andor says that one of
the facilities that he was in as a child was sippo
that's brand new to the Star Wars Universe there
are a lot of people in a lot of places that are
brand new to Star Wars they introduced in this
episode but you also remember that a lot of his
backstory he lied to luthen about so he could be
lying about that just because he's a pathological
liar later in the episode after arvel finds out
about the kyber crystal the Jedi Crystal that
Andor has and gets really pissed off at him
he explains the actual reason why he joined the
Rebellion is because the Empire basically caused
his brother to kill himself and before that his
brother ran a tree farm which is why he made the
tree ax metaphor earlier in the episode and a
couple you were mentioning this in my earlier
videos but yes he is the actor who played micro
in Netflix's The Punisher we get a little bit
of mon mothma in this episode we see a little
bit more of her around The Breakfast Table is
a very opulent spread like remember she's meant
to be one of the richest people on course one
of the most powerful people too in the Senate
but the breakfast is just meant to give you a
Vibe for her home life we never really met her
husband in the Star Wars Canon before like the
Canon had never mentioned him but before and it
never mentioned that she had a daughter whose
name Leida sounds very similar to Leia maybe
that has something to do with her joining the
Rebellion later now it sounds like right now she's
already trying to help the Rebellion on the DL but
she's not all in completely so what might wind
up happening like early Theory press F to pay
respects her family might die in some kind of
Imperial accident where the Empire might lead
to their deaths and that might cause her to go all
in on the Rebellion because it sounds like a lot
of these early Rebels are super hardcore and most
of them join because they lost someone very close
to them it's kind of hard to pick up what's going
on with her daughter with this brief conversation
that they have she comes off a little bit like
a typical spoiled rich girl but I think the idea
is that she falsely believes that mon mothma is
one of those typical politicians that everybody
hates it sounds like she's trying to take her to
some charitable cause that she's working on but it
sounds like her daughter thinks that she doesn't
actually care about what she's doing if they do
wind up killing her daughter off during the series
maybe before that happens she'll find out what mon
mothma is really doing like no no I'm actually
trying to help people on the DL we're trying to
get rid of this Empire and later in the car ride
on Coruscant with her husband we get a little bit
more of a tour of the exterior of course or the
upper levels of course and you have to remember
the entire planet is covered in the city and
each level of the city is just built on the old
layers of the city as they go along so they're
like thousands of years of City just buried
underneath the top layers you wind up exploring a
lot more of course during the Clone Wars episode
so if you really like them going on tours all over
different places of the city and different lower
levels they actually did that in Clone Wars
Episodes but it sounds like on their car ride
home when their husband starts asking her about
what she's actually doing with these charitable
causes they want to make him come off as less of a
dirt bag like he actually does kind of care about
what she's doing back on all Donnie when they
start drinking that Dre milk Dre was a former
human Jedi Padawan during the Clone Wars but I
think this Dre animal is meant to be something
that's completely different and new to the Star
Wars Canon the really old navigation device that
nemec gives him sounds like it's pre-empire so it
could be Republic it could be a little bit older
than he makes it sound like it's ancient and I
think the way he talks to Andor and a lot of the
other conversations he has throughout this part of
the episode is they're supposed to slowly Inspire
him to care more about the actual state of the
Galaxy like he starts to hear the stories of these
other people why they join the rebellion and they
start to inspire him a little bit more because at
this point in the story he still doesn't really
care about the Rebellion he doesn't care about
the Empire the only thing he actually wants is
to find his sister so he'll do anything he has
to to further that cause and that's the whole idea
here's working for luthen pulling this job because
he thinks he's going to get a bunch of money and
that will help him find his sister but it sounds
like part of his Arc through the series is just
growing to believe in their cause because during
Rogue one it seems like he's full on Rebellion
the other resistance members not really knowing
what's going on with their escape vessel is just
to show you that a lot of what they're doing is
done by the seat of their pants and they're kind
of making things up as they go along hoping for
the best like at any point any of this could fail
and they could all die andor's fake name that he's
using for the mission is Clem because that was
the name he wanted to use that he told Luther and
that was his adoptive father's name even though he
didn't tell that part to luthen part of his fake
backstory they create for this mission is that
he's going to be a transfer from all Kenzie in
this other base that's just another place on this
same all Donny planet and I love the transition
during the scene because right after he gets done
being asked whether or not he knows how to March
and act as an imperial Soldier they transitioned
to the Imperial soldiers actually marching in
formation on pharynx everybody running around in
the black uniforms those are just regular Imperial
officers Imperial officers have a couple different
types of uniforms they wear the black ones and the
green ones but they're all meant to be part of the
Imperial Navy and the whole idea is that they're
just furthering their mission and taking over this
area which was previously ruled by the corporation
because there's 12 episodes and we're still pretty
early on in the series we'll probably see a lot
more of them on this planet especially with bix's
character back on all Donny they get a fly by by
one of the Tie fighters going back to the base and
we find out what's going on with Lieutenant Gorn
and his backstory like why it is that he's helping
them enjoying the Rebellion when he's already
being paid so well as an imperial Lieutenant they
basically explained that the Empire is eventually
planning on tearing down the entire area where
the celestial phenomenon is viewed this big sacred
place for the people they're basically going
to mow over it and use the planet as more of a
jumping off point for more of their operations
like a much bigger hub for the Imperial Fleet
so they're basically going to pave over most of
the planet so not only are they going to lose the
celestial phenomenon that everybody keeps talking
about during the episode like it's this very
revered thing like even the lower grade Imperial
officers are really excited about watching it like
they say you have to be up there to see it even
though we can't all be up there but also Gorn
at some point in the past fell in love with one of
the local women and that's probably his connection
to why he grew to love the celestial phenomenon
so much and when the Empire found out about his
liaison with a Woman They withheld his promotion
and eventually something happened and the woman
wound up leaving it sounds like she's still alive
but it sounds like something caused her to take
off so he lost his promotion he lost his woman and
pretty soon they're going to lose this Celestial
phenomenon to the m Empire and that's why he
wants to help the Rebellion back on Coruscant
and the Imperial Security Bureau Dedra references
hosnian prime again her aid references Kessel
fondor jakku Kessel obviously where the spice
mines are mentioned several times all across the
Star Wars movies and TV shows fondor is another
planet where they have the Imperial shipyards they
referenced this earlier in the season in jakku
is obviously from the sequel Trilogy it's the
location of one of the emperor's secret vaults
of special weapons artifacts contingency plans
it becomes a big deal in the fall of the Empire
after the events of Return of the Jedi base cay
that he mentions is brand new to Star Wars in the
steer Guard base is the Imperial base that luthen
mentioned earlier it's brand new to Star Wars as
well but it's also the place where Andor stole
the star path unit from initially in the whole
pattern here that she's trying to figure out is
her learning about the Rebellion just in general
like slowly eventually tracking luthin in all of
his cohorts down we jump back to the Imperial base
at all daddy so we see a little bit of the inside
and the ship that they're going to be using to try
and Escape that they were talking about earlier in
the episode we also get to see the actual payroll
that they'll be stealing like this giant pile of
what looks like gold basically they'd be like
a version of Imperial credits like there's a
couple different versions of money inside the
Star Wars universe but during the reign of the
Empire Imperial credits were like the main form
of currency and Gorn basically tries to create
a situation that will cause most of the people
working there to not be around during the actual
Heist when it's going down just to make it a
little bit easier for everyone remember the whole
idea is they're going to be pulling the heist off
while the celestial phenomenon is happening so
most of that base most Imperial officers there
will be outside watching it and not inside the
base watching the actual payroll and then back at
luthen shot the communicator that he's watching
here listening to is the same device that Bix was
trying to contact him on earlier it sounds like
he's using this old transmitter technology just
to communicate with all the other people he's
working with in the Rebellion but because there
are Easter eggs all over his shop remember his
whole thing is he's a collector he deals in stolen
and found quote artifacts although I think part
of the ideas that they were stolen in pilford from
other people like a lot of them are Jedi artifacts
pilfered from Jedi temples but the main ones they
really want you to focus on are what look like a
Jedi holocron in a Sith holocron Sith holocrons
are the Triangular ones the Jedi holocrons are
the square looking ones they're a little bit
bigger than holocrons have been depicted in the
past but it just sounds like that's what they want
you to think of when you look at them like oh wait
a minute those are kind of like holocrons some of
the other major Jedi artifacts in the front of his
shot that we saw previously on the series were
part of the Jedi mural of the mortis Gods which
was featured during the Clone Wars Episodes which
is actually a really big deal surprisingly would
actually have it this looks like placoon's mask
and in the background here after the episode Sam
Whitworth said that this is basically starkiller's
armor so he said that he's kind of in the episode
like I said I'm kind of in the episode if you
really bend over backwards you could say that
that makes Starkiller Canon not officially but
kind of Canon the stones on the upper right here
look kind of like the stones from Indiana Jones
Temple of Doom and I'm not sure what this neck
piece on the wall is like it's very prominent
so if you think you recognize this neck piece
in the background here just let me know what you
think it is in the comments below but this is just
a small part of his shop so I'm sure as they show
more scenes in here in different angles we'll see
more Easter eggs in the background but it was a
relatively Short episode there wasn't a whole lot
going on during it so if you think you spotted
any other big Easter eggs or references that I
didn't talk about in the video just write them
Below in the comments there's a link for all my
Andor videos in the description below you can
also click here for my brand new house of the
Dragon episode 8 video and click here for my brand
new black panther of wakanda forever trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!